[Musique]
le sentiment que ça y est
nous plong
dedans soulagé ou un peu stressé encore
les dere les deux parce que presque
presque au bout de avant que nous lar
complètement parce que après quand nous
est en spectacle ben là là
[Musique]
déroule Dav a ce projet là depuis un an
à peu près et ça fait des mois des mois
des mois qu'il travaille dessus nous
l'AV imaginé avec mon madame nous dit
bah allons faire un spectacle
ça n essay plonge le spectateur dans
l'ambiance cinéma un peu et et puis
allons essay voir si pas moyen fan de TR
centeur que de ça va loin dans dansre
pensée on veut transmettre un message ça
veut dire qu'on est ensemble et on peut
réaliser des choses même si c'est
inimaginable même si c'est impensable
mais on y arrivera parce qu'on est
ensemble
c'est tout un système de distribution
d'air qui va permettre de passer des
parfums dans tout cet endroit là jusqu'à
la scène que les 40 et quelques m donc
là nous l' inventé un nouveau système de
ventilation avec des sacs de pressing
que nous l'a pris sur 400 m nous l'
déployé avec à
l'intérieur mon pays par exemple c'est
quel
centeur
les senteurs c'est quelque chose ce sont
des mémoires qu'on n'oublie pas qui sont
cachées à l'intérieur de nous et quand
on sent des des odeurs ça ramène tout de
suite à des souvenirs qu'on met au fond
de nous-même tout le temps à chaque fois
et là c'est impossible de passer à
travers c'est vraiment des souvenirs
[Musique]
d'enfance avec DESV on a bossé en amont
et lui il m'a donné un peu son monde
qu'est-ce qu'il voyait qu'est-ce qu'il
sentait pourquoi cette chanson était
faite quelle couleur enfin voilà on a
bossé un peu là-dessus très une vraie
création c'est un truc un peu foufou ce
qu'on a
[Musique]
fait ce qui est très particulier c'est
que d'abord on a peu de temps qu'on a on
a commencé lundi donc on est quasiment
sur une à la fois une création
répétition en même temps donc le défi
est vraiment très très élevé et puis
avec des gens qui se connaissent pas
est-ce que ne se côoie pas surtout euh
alors ils peuvent se voir sur l'année
mais là ils sont tous réunis dans un
même lieu on est 23 à travailler sur le
sur sur l'événement donc forcément ça
demande la coordination la plus la plus
juste
[Musique]
possible viens fait un avec nous viens
parce que nous ça fait un ça vive un
affaire inédit
[Musique]
exceptionnel
dans